yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm John and
in this video i'm revealing 14
incredible scenes cut from frozen to
plus the amazing honor and olaf songs
that you'll wish have been in the movie
if you want to jump to any individual
deleted scenes or songs this timestamps
in the video description was an
intriguing deleted scene from early in
the movie called else's dream which was
the original inspiration for Elsa's big
ballad into the unknown the scene takes
place just after the sisters fall asleep
together following their game of
charades
then honor is woken up by snowflakes
falling from a cloud created by else's
dream
[Music]
this deleted scene shows how else's ice
magic can manifest physically even when
she's sleeping and that she can
unconsciously project moving images from
her dreams the images of a dinner and
the enchanted forest from this discarded
scene became the basis for the dreamlike
memories and visions that appear to Elsa
during into the unknown else's dream
continues and takes a nightmarish turn
as images of arendelle Ian's soldiers
appear in the forest and the strong
emotions this generates an Elsa bring
out even more of her magic creating a
mini storm inside the bedroom
[Music]
in that final moment Elsa literally
freezes the rain outside the castle into
thousands of ice crystals which was
where the idea came from to fill the sky
in arendelle with crystals at the end of
into the unknown and then the
fascinating deleted scene from early in
the movie sees Elsa and Anna discover a
hidden room inside arendelle Castle
where they uncover secret studies being
carried out into the origins of Elsa's
powers magical arts dangers of dark
magic father miss studying magic oh
you're studying me too wait what this is
some sort of journal I can find no
record of a human with power like hers
but for the ancient myths with their
tragic feats wait a minute this isn't
father's handwriting it's mother's if we
look more closely at the journal we can
see a page about the white gloves else's
father gave her in the first movie in an
attempt to suppress her ice magic the
gloves will help see conceal it don't
fear it don't matter - and the journal
entry which mentions the ancient myths
with their tragic fates helps us
understand why Elsa's parents wanted to
try and contain their daughter's powers
for fear that her magical nature would
lead her to tragedy this moment would
also have set up the idea of Elsa is a
mythical being and foreshadowed her fate
later in the movie when she freezes deep
inside at a Harlan the final part of the
deleted scene also gives the sisters
another shocking revelation
these next pages are in English but also
North altar in Norse the hell drian but
that language is forbidden why wouldn't
mother know it
or dare use it
whatever eat evil my people did whatever
darkness still roams our forest I can no
longer turn my back on the past this
tells us that no soldier culture was
actively suppressed inside arendelle and
that's probably why our Doudna kept her
research secret including writing in her
own language and perhaps why she hadn't
yet told her daughters that she was no
soldier the deleted scene helps explain
just how much a dinner and Agner were
searching for answers about how to deal
with Elsa's magic and shows why they
attempted the voyage to a to Harlan it
also reveals how the sisters ended up
with them but the snuffle dress calf
this is also likely where Elsa and Anna
would have sung the deleted song I seek
the truth a wonderful song deleted from
the beginning of the movie was a solo
for Anna called home in which she sings
about how much he loves arendelle the
intention behind this beautiful number
was to establish how Anna will be the
perfect queen for arendelle by the end
of the film
it shows how she's completely at ease
and loves everything about her Kingdom
either way for what it's worth this
perfect corner of the earth
[Music]
mom and it would also have highlighted
just how much honor had to lose by her
decision to destroy the dam that
threatens to flood arendelle sweetness
of this song also contrasts perfectly
with her much sadder song the next right
thing which she sings at her absolute
lowest after realizing that both her
sister and Olaf are gone home would also
contrasted more with Elsa's big number
into the unknown highlighting the
differences between the sisters and
foreshadowing the end of the movie
in other words honor loves her Kingdom
and her place is there hey come here
take this coin and go buy a custard bun
for everyone okay
whereas Elsa is drawn by a call from
afar and her destiny lives outside
arendelle suddenly the filmmakers had to
cut the song and replace it with the
ensemble number some things never
changed when they realized they still
hadn't set things up sufficiently to
show what was at stake for Elsa Kristoff
and Olaf when arendelle came under
threat however they did take the overall
theme of the deleted song and one of its
lyrics and compressed it into the line
that honor says to Olaf just before they
sing some things never change
I have you and Elsa and Kristoff and
Sven and the gates are open wide and I'm
not alone anymore
I'm multiple me is a great song by Olaf
that ended up being cut from the final
film
it was the movie's original way to
explain why the magical snowman no
longer needed the little snow flurry
that Elsa gave him in the first movie to
stop him from melting prison but not the
questioned that's right I just learned
to read and I liked the big words
imagine a lot of fans would have loved
to have seen it in the movie in the
final film this songs replaced with the
scene where Arno visits the little
snowman and casually asks him about his
new permafrost Wally basks in the warmth
of an autumn day there's a great shot in
the first teaser trailer for frozen two
of our know grabbing Kristoff sword and
attacking someone or something off
camera that scene never made it into the
final movie because the story changed
and it wasn't needed any longer however
when the filmmakers discovered just how
much fans loved seeing Anna wield a
sword they made sure she had one in the
movie albeit in a slightly different way
in the final film when the gang was
scared by the noise of approaching
strangers in the forest honor grabs an
ice sword from one of El
as ice memory statues and uses it to
defend the group against the North
Andhra and errand aliens who suddenly
appear
Christoph's part in frozen to underwent
some major changes as the movie
developed at the beginning of the
original story Kristoff was a lord in
arendelle having been promoted again
from his official title of ice master
and deliverer that Elsa gave him in the
end of the first film
however given Christoph's humble origins
he was finding it difficult fitting in
to arendelle II in high society and he
was keeping his feelings about this a
secret presumably to avoid upsetting
honor the truth eventually came out
though in a deleted scene with Kristoff
and the knock water spirit hello
I think he's offering you a ride are you
afraid hah no afraid of what afraid he
won't see truth in your heart and he'll
drown you are you what no of course not
then get on uh-huh okay see I know it
would be fine okay except for the part
where his heart's full of lies
apparently
[Music]
you okay you good I'm good
thank you except you're lying about
something
I don't like fancy shoes or regal
jackets or polite conversations no
because it's not a thing no no do you
even like your life and arendelle it off
just tell me the truth
No so it was all a lie all of it Anna I
don't think we should get married
I think this scene would have come
around the middle of the movie after the
gang end to the enchanted forest the
knock did appear briefly to Olaf in the
forest in the final film and this
breakup between Anna and Kristoff would
have been an alternate way to separate
them over all this unused scene feels
just a little too unhappy though
compared to the final movie where the
coupler split up in the forest more
because they're a little out of sync
with each other and because anna is
focused on helping her sister with their
quest to outer Harlin however there is
another deleted Kristoff and honor scene
in which he proposes to her in a grand
glorious and hilarious way when he sings
to her and you can watch my full
breakdown of that in my frozen to
deleted ending video the opening scene
and prologue of frozen - which tells the
story of younger dinner and Agner and
the enchanted forest was changed many
times during the movies development as
it had to match up with any other story
changes in the main part of the film on
the blu-ray there's not her--let
prologue that would have shown how a
dune or a nag nor escape the fighting
between the arendelle Ian's and the
North ultra in this version when the
spirits are angered young Agner almost
falls off a cliff before a dune a
rescues him
Matthias then picks them both up and
puts them on a cart fleeing the chaos
inside the forest and heading back to
arendelle in the final film Agner says
he never knew who saved him that day and
instead of the deleted scene what we get
is Elsa seeing memories of the past
inside at a Harlin and learning that it
was a donor who smuggled herself and an
unconscious Agner onto a cart that took
them out of the forest an interesting
detail in this alternate prologue is
that there's a mysterious human
character in the forest who can either
shape
door moves with the appearance of a
reindeer this mystery humans save the
dinner at one point and is also attacked
by Actos father the king of arendelle
this is a star sterling Kate Browns
character Matias also had a different
storyline in earlier versions of the
film originally the high-ranking
military man was going to be trapped in
the enchanted forest all by himself
rather than with his fellow errant
aliens as happens in the final film but
tears his original story would have also
included him singing a song though that
ended up being deleted from the movie as
ultimately it didn't fit in with the
final story the trailer scene of the
wind spirit Gale uncovering young agna
from a bed of leaves in the forest and
blowing him into the air didn't make it
into the final film either the reason
for that is that the scene is actually
part of a test that the animators did to
learn how to animate the personality of
the wind spirit the longer version of
this scene is on the blu-ray which also
shows some cute moments between younger
Doudna and Agner another cut trailer
scene shows a younger Doudna carrying a
baby reindeer as an authority greet the
errand aliens and this trailer scene of
Kristoff riding a herd of charging
reindeer wasn't in the final movie
either the trailer scene of Olaf
standing next to Elsa as she tries to
put out the fires in the forest was
altered for the final movie where Elsa
fights the fire spirit alone and in
another change from the trailer as this
shot of Queen Adina looking out of the
bedroom window at the Northern Lights
was replaced with the Doudna carrying
young Elsa to look out of the window
together there's also a much darker
original ending to frozen - in which
Disney almost killed off Elsa and
destroyed arendelle to learn all about
that as well as Kristof's alternate
proposal to other tap here or follow the
link in the video description and if you
want to see all the deleted scenes in
full check out the blu-ray I've added
links to that in the description so
which of these deleted scenes and songs
do you wish a bit in the movie and which
are you glad that were cut leave your
thoughts in the comments below
if you enjoyed this and a share and
alike a hugely appreciated tapleft to
watch another frozen - video or tap
write for something else you're sure to
like thanks for watching and see you
next time you pick a movie lovers